now let's start first by discussing
which foods would be most affected I
understand baked goods are especially
dependent on these artificial trans fats
that's right baked goods and also some
canned frosting it's one of them their
new trans fats are used to for certain
textures and to be able to make the
foods shelf stable so they last longer
on your grocery store shelves so you've
got pie crusts cake mixes and some
biscuits that you know might have some
trouble finding substitutions 24 trans
fats and the same with canned frosting
because it helps make it spreadable so
does that mean certain companies can get
waivers if they apply for what would be
the conditions under which they would be
granted waivers that's a little bit
unclear the conditions as of now so the
FDA would will not allow any trans fats
and in food unless a company comes to
them with data that shows that the low
levels that they would like to use in
their food would not harm the American
public when they eat them so we don't
know what that data exactly will look
like yet some of the grocery
Manufacturers Association says that you
know they're going to be able to prove
that so there might be some small
amounts used but they will have to get
FDA approval to use them okay so they'll
have to take costly steps to get there
in the meantime a lot of companies had
been anticipating this and we're already
looking at alternatives are there any
estimates out there in terms of how much
this would cost the food industry the
FDA's estimated it to be about 6.2
billion that's over 20 years so they
didn't put out a year-by-year estimate
that I've seen at least not yet and so
it would be that amount to find the
substitutions and also to take the you
know kind of real able their products so
as I mentioned this ruling can't have
been a surprise and we've discussed how
many companies have used alternative
ingredients in anticipation that they
would need to reduce the trans fat
composition of their food are there
alternative ingredients necessarily
healthier for the American public that's
a good question there so one of the
probably you know go to ingredients that
they could sub
would be palm oil and a scientist that I
spoke to said that you know it it's not
the best thing in the world but it is at
least a little bit healthier whereas
trans fat can raise your bad cholesterol
and lower your good cholesterol
something like palm oil might just raise
the bad cholesterol a little bit gotcha
and New York City was the first banned
trans fats from restaurants it was
followed by some other places but this
is on a federal level regarding the food
that you buy at the grocery store that's
right yeah and also you know it could it
could include food that is cooked in
restaurants as well okay gotcha what by
the way a quick question here Anna was
there ever a time when transat was
considered healthy or not necessarily
dangerous I feel like once upon a time
people were convinced that this was a
good alternative yeah much like a lot of
things that we eat and what we're told
on how they affect our health you know
trans fats have been in use for decades
and where I think you know thought to be
at least better than say like lard or
something along those lines but
obviously thinking has changed since
then yeah certainly is it's a victim of
its time